[Music]
previously on wandavision
not saying previously on previously on
the episode previously on want division
also play that again and tell me
elizabeth olsen herself doesn't sound
like she's bored with these tediously on
one division segments
previously on one division she throws
that voice over away like it's a gum
wrapper she found in an old jacket
these are runes wanda only the witch
that casts the runes can use her magic
spoiling your own show by what you put
in the previously on segment
this back-breaking pose he was gonna
burn westview to the ground just to get
what he wants
sure so hayward appears to not be that
great but he may have legitimate reasons
for his actions
we don't know i like that the show
leaves his villainy a bit nuanced and
doesn't feel the need for him to do
something truly evil and drastic like
oh i don't know attempted child murder
this is chaos magic
wand see we know that agatha is bad
because she has extensions dark makeup
in this sock neck
i take power from the undeserving it's
kind of my thing
and kind of vague what does undeserving
even mean on a scale of super bowl 41
peyton manning to green book
exactly how undeserving is wanda and why
once you focus on albino vision's
costume crotch floss you really do feel
bad for the undeniable chafing that must
be taking place after each footfall
his poor poor underbits is it really you
asks the mind reader easily capable of a
quick scanneroo
why is caucasian here pretending like he
cares about wanda at all instead of just
sneaking up on her and taking her
out and i was told you were powerful she
is which is why this damsel in distress
setup is all the more infuriating
deus ex ocula i could fix it can you
yes she can wanda builder
geez disney you don't even own that
property there's nothing sacred
like pretty much every villain before
him robo blanco just saunters out of a
fire after hanging out there for a while
and waiting for the conversation in
before attacking you could almost make
an excuse for humans who may want a
showboat but he's a computer with a
directive diet
it wouldn't be a marvel property without
same fighting same in the finale
complete with quick cuts in cg and with
wanda and agatha later it happens twice
here i thought this show might escape
those tropes but nope proverbs 26 11
comes through again and no
i'm not gonna look it up for you and yes
it does include a puke reference
because the bible is hardcore like that
you must be destroyed
and so we watch vision have his forehead
bling yanked out again hey
good thinking viz and why did you do
that last time
hey it's my favorite member of the
bureau who i had brought here to mission
control instead of locked in a room
for some reason no one sees this
including the security detail standing
directly behind him
are we sure suare doesn't stand for some
worthless oblivious random dudes
you could be a part of that victory
jimmy if only you had a little more
vision i'll be the one to handle the
terrible name based puns around here
i'm betting he didn't put much thought
at all into that one and that's worth a
wholesome
i said they were terrible when in doubt
just break the fence for that perfect
shot
no need to make it look like the fence
has flaws in other places nope just make
your hero facehole and call it a day
did you know there's an entire chapter
devoted to you in the dark hole
agatha slacks off on enunciating the d
and for a second i thought the book of
the damned was called the dark hole
which if it hadn't already been the name
of my high school hyper pop band might
have actually been better
oh good i'm not the only person that
keeps an eight and a half by eleven head
shot of myself in my man cave
i was teased relentlessly by my dude
bros but honestly you never know when
you need one
you're ralph boner
boner no a thousand times no first if
your name is boner you've heard this
joke a million times and are not going
to beavis your response to your own name
second why does ralph only have super
speed in that necklace
if she was using him anyway why didn't
you give him other powers like super
strength or even a smidgen of
intelligence
why not fully use the power of boners to
your advantage agatha
and finally the fact that you look
exactly like pietro from another movie
that was all the coincidence
i'm the fan and you must submit to all
my theories on the multiverse and
mutants and i wrote a whole thesis
already and how dare you act like this
is your story to tell when my mind was
already made up
my husband's on a business trip tell him
i love him
this brings up a good point how are
there not hundreds of loved ones outside
this town that haven't been able to
reach their children spouses parents
college buddies etc
wouldn't those people have contacted the
authorities your grief is poisoning us
i trust your metaphor when you can just
have your characters explicitly spell it
out
anyone else worried about mr hart he
never shows up again after the first
episode and now i'm wondering if he
tried to eat steak again when vision
wasn't around to do a metaphysical
tracheotomy
if you won't let us go just let us die
please i will wait what i will let you
go
oh i thought this was actually about to
get fresh and interesting again
head laser head laser head laser head
laser head laser
excitement you tied your family to this
twisted world and now one can't exist
without the other
thanks for breaking this emotional
moment up by having a character
explicitly lay out what we already know
why won't you trust me marvel i've been
watching the whole time
look i don't mind a bit of an homage but
this is so the incredibles they should
have to pay whatever company owns pixar
some royalties for this
not to beat a dead vision here but how
does any of this fight make any sense
if they can phase through each other why
do any of their punches land ever
why do super powerful beings always end
up punching each other
why are you doing this my programming
directive is to destroy the vision
but my script directive is to pause for
philosophical conversations occasionally
as well
i request elaboration every [ __ ] fans
response after the
end of this [ __ ] episode somehow
makes it into the [ __ ] script
oh yes here's a wholesome mcu moment
where a man decides to straight up
murder some children
it's okay though because we get to see
monica's sweet powers so nobody really
cares too much but this is still an
absolute sin
also that's right monica's entire
storyline about getting her powers boils
down to absorbing a few bullets that the
kids could have taken care of themselves
anyway
if you look up anticlimactic in the
dictionary it just says we were going to
put a picture of monica rambo here but
we were too bored
have fun in prison ladies and gentlemen
the entirety of darcy's finale story arc
you are familiar with the thought
experiment the ship of theseus in the
field of identity metaphysics
no but i am familiar with the
philosophical [ __ ] of plot theseus
in the field of convenient and
underwhelming story resolutions
[Music]
that was easy i am a vision and so
visbyno flies out of the hex without
becoming damaged from the cell
restructuring properties of said hex
and then finds a simple place to destroy
himself as that is his directive
speaking of directives albision also
said he was going to destroy
wanda has that somehow changed now that
he saw her in some memories memories
which revealed that she had once
murdered him
you see the difference between you and
me
that you did this on purpose how does
wanna know anything about this moment in
agatha's past
did she watch that last episode too you
are the scarlet witch i suppose now that
we're seeing a long ago memory from
agatha's past turn into a zombie
prophecy we should all jump right in and
believe whatever they say
i love you so i hurt you
this rune reveal is clever i guess
except how and when did wanda do this
how did she know how
why did she play possum and pretend to
be drained of her power how did agatha
suck all the power
in if she had no magic how was she even
flying with no magic
once wanda had the runes up there why
not just lock her down instead of
letting her enemy and her own family
think she was being destroyed first
and if she wasn't faking how did she get
her powers back even if you think you
have answers to some of these questions
this scene is hella confusing
honestly nothing makes any sense now
that the show has been completely ruined
and red beats purple because reasons and
i'm happy i think
oh god you don't know what you've done
nope it's almost like someone should
have told her all about the pros and
cons of coming into her power before
provoking her to come unto her power but
then where would we be for all the
upcoming mcu content eh what
i assumed agatha had been fighting
barefoot this entire time you know
considering she wizard of oz or battle
boots back by the car
i'll give you the role you chose the
nosy neighbor
for how long and on what show is
westview not going back to normal
what even is this punishment should we
head on nope
because you can't go home until it's
dark outside it's far more dramatic that
way
haha yes there we go instant evening
your mother and i
very proud of you both very proud and
now we're going to release you to the
existential nothingness even though we
could probably simply leave the bubble
intact over just our house
enjoy annihilation toodles it's somewhat
believable that the very logical vision
would embrace his impending death with
the sort of casual willp
but the kids were to believe they
hunkered down in bed after a mad rush of
superpower adrenaline all day
mom and dad are like well we love you
good night and the boys just closed
their eyes and asked zero questions
about the collapsing glowing wall or
why they were being disintegrated
earlier mcu said
skip you vision
are the piece of the mind stone that
lives in me
might be next a plot convenience i'm
calling it
i'm not crying you're crying no
seriously i'm not crying because despite
this entire series supposedly being
about grief and letting go we end up
with another vision in the world with
the memories of the real vision and
there are never actual consequences for
anything
for dramatic sake it sure is good all
these people just hung around out here
instead of running to call loved ones or
running away from the giant witch battle
for shelter or any of a number of other
things that actual humans would do in
this situation
also fine what wanda did was super
[ __ ] up whether she meant to or not
but is
anyone going to ask her for a new town
pool before she goes
they'll never know what you sacrificed
for them oh come on
she didn't sacrifice anything for them
she created this whole thing and sunken
placed them into her fantasy having her
nightmares and her loss had already
happened before they even entered the
picture wanda is the villain
pure and simple you know it i know it
i'm just wondering if marvel will ever
know it
given the chance and giving your power
i'd bring my mom back then you've
learned nothing and none of us have
learned anything and why did we even all
go through this
[Music]
that's it that's it what about all the
winks at the multiverse the fox universe
x-men the aerospace engineer
nexus it's one thing to have reveals
that may be a bit underwhelming but it's
another thing to leave every single
loose thread
that you specifically dangled hanging
there are so many unconsummated teases
in this show that they should have just
titled the final episode plot blocked
also what about the whole tv show
concept i may have been wrong about a
couple things the created by wandavision
sin and thinking the messenger was in on
it come to mind but the vast majority of
the observations still ring true
how was she controlling the episodes
were they airing in real time
why did she even air them in the first
place why didn't she do a who's the boss
episode what was
up with those commercials who aired
those and were those people in the town
and what about
beekeeper guy for the love of god how
did she rewind time and what does that
mean happen to beekeeper guy
so fine take a couple sins back for the
times i was wrong
but i'm adding another 10 cents for the
times i was right then here's an extra
five just for beekeeper guy
he'd like to meet with you where
the theater addict
multitasking
you've just been erased wanna hang out
with us on a live stream we don't care
if you're on the toilet in your mom's
basement or
in the broom closet just put on some
deodorant and join us during sin week
2021 march 22nd through
26th we'll release three extra sins
videos and go live
four times to hang out with you all you
have to do is become a sin club member
at patreon.com cinemasins do it now
that way you're the first to learn about
our evil plans and if you join today you
have time to watch over 70 exclusive
videos and podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd so you want
to play rough
do you
it really was no miracle what happened
was just this
in your head you're bluffing
mr son of a [ __ ] let's play some
cards nice tricks i've been led to
understand that tricks
are exclusively for children
i just wanted to see you clearly
good luck and remember
[Music]
don't pick it up